this can really help us understand the
modern world and can help us understand
the modern crisis
and i think that
in order to kind of understand the
modern crisis the first thing we have to
understand
is that the modern world is not only
born out of technical knowledge that is
there's a direct relationship between
technical knowledge and the relationship
with angels
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
so last week i gave a talk at a college
here in quebec
looking at the book of enoch and its
relationship to
the modern ecological apocalyptic
narrative you could say
and i got such a good reaction on social
media a lot of people wondering if i
would put it up not realizing that it
was in french i decided i would make a
virgin for the english channel which
will be a little more detailed
a little more focused on some of the
details from the book of enoch and how
it can give us a key to understanding
some of the things that are happening to
us today and so before we go into the
book of enoch itself it's very important
to understand first of all the narrative
creation which is in scripture because
of course the book of enoch
is a let's say
it expands on the creation narrative and
especially on the flood narrative and so
it's good to kind of understand the
basic structure of the fall so that we
can understand how the book of enoch and
the way describes the relationships
between these fallen angels and the
women and civilization is really just an
expansion of something with something
which is already there in the origin in
the fall itself
so of course we know that in the
beginning god created heaven and heavens
and the earth he creates the world and
he places adam and eve in a garden
now traditionally especially in the
syrian tradition the garden is
understood as a mountain and that's very
important because we're going to see
that the fall and the different
analogies of the fall will appear all
through the text and will also
ultimately appear in the book of enoch
and what it means to move towards the
flood and so in this image we see adam
and eve in the central garden with the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
there in the middle
the fountain at the bottom and we see
the serpent around the tree
and adam and eve are tempted and it is
by desire
for knowledge that they are tempted it's
very important to understand that
especially according to once again
not just the syrian fathers this time
but also people like saint ernest of
lyon
there's a sense in which
the the fruit of the knowledge of good
and evil was going to be given to adam
and eve ultimately but the reason why
they
it made them fall was because they took
it too fast they took it
through an act of desire it says that
you know the woman saw that the fruit
was good to eat and so she reached up
and grabbed it for herself
and because of that gesture of taking it
for yourself and taking it in desire
that is what will ultimately lead to a
fall and as we understand this it will
also be a way to kind of understand the
difference between the normal christian
vision of the world and the more
luciferian vision of the world which
understands
uh let's say
the fall even as something good you see
that in gnostic teaching you see that
even in in some of the moderns like
people like jung seems to suggest that
that uh there is something good about
the taking of the fruit ultimately in
the story of scripture god will turn
this into a good but we need to
understand it all as a fall
in the in the moment itself because it
is done through a
a sense of self-aggrandizement and a a
sense of desire a
slavery to our own desire which will
become the model for everything else
that goes about and so we see now in
this image we see adam and eve falling
on the on the left here we see the angel
throwing them out of paradise
with the flaming sword which is not very
flaming in this but nonetheless and then
we see adam and eve working the ground
in the garden we see eve uh you know
sewing and making making thread we see
adam tilling and we see them especially
covered by the garments of skin and so
we see that when they fall god says
cursed is the ground for your sake in
toil you shall eat of it all the days of
your life for thorn and tooth thistles
it shall bring forth to you and you
shall eat the herb of the field so it's
very important first of all to
understand
right away the image of the fall because
the fall it means coming closer to the
earth but in the sense losing control of
the earth
it's important to see that
in the outset god says to adam and eve
that they can eat from any fruit that
they found in the trees of the garden
but now as they fall god tells them that
they will
that they will eat the herbs from the
field so now they're eating from the
ground before they were taking the fruit
which was up in the structure in the in
the trees and now they're eating
directly from the ground and you can
contrast that as well or compare it to
for example when nebuchadnezzar falls in
the book of daniel and where you know as
he falls god tells him once again that
he will eat the grass of the field like
the animals eat the grass of the field
and so you can see in the story of
nebuchadnezzar he becomes an animal and
starts to eat of the grass of the field
and here again adam is moving down the
mountain into animality and
in doing so he is now eating the
the herb that comes from the ground
but he's then also receiving the the
garments of skin
there is of course the notion that they
have to work that now the world becomes
opposed to them that as they leave the
balance of the garden this unity that
they had in the garden they are they
bring they're brought about into a world
of opposites and one of the basic
opposites is now the opposition with the
world outside of them the inside outside
relationship and the dual the dual
relationship that is
part of reality now becomes a form of
opposition not a form of complementarity
we see that of course in the
relationship between adam and eve
themselves
eve is supposed to be the complement to
adam the the let's say the the person
that accompanies him that comes from
inside and now there's an opposition
which gets set up between
eve and the serpent between eve and adam
and of course now in general between man
and the world itself and that is
represented by the creation of thorn the
the the coming about of thorns in the
world and so now adam has to work very
hard in order to
to receive the bread from the ground and
ultimately that fall will continue and
adam will end up falling all the way
down until he becomes the dust and of
course the fall is not just falling it's
a fragmentation it's a moving down the
order of creation down into the animals
down into animality and then ultimately
down into the dust itself or
down into the water which we'll see of
course in the story of the flood
now of then it says that adam that god
made for adam the two nicks of skin i've
talked about this quite a bit in my uh
different lectures but to recap it a
little the garments of skin are the
origin of technology themselves that is
it's the origin of technology itself
that is god places a
shell around adam
in the world of death he takes
adam is falling into the into the
animality he's falling down into
the the the lower aspects of creation as
he moves into this duality but then
there is a trick which god can use which
is to use those elements of death to
also create some a barrier to stop adam
from falling further or falling too fast
you could say of preserving this kind of
moment of of life and death you could
say
to give adam the chance to change that's
ultimately what that's for and so these
garments of skin are placed on adam and
eve in order to preserve them in the
world of the fall
and it becomes the very key to
understanding technology which is a
gathering
of the things below to cover us in a in
a world of danger and of course at the
outset adam is covered by these garments
of skin on his own and so he takes a
garment of death to protect themselves
from the thorns but then later that will
start to grow
and so the garments of skin will get
bigger they will start to become more
and more heavy we could say
and this of course happened at the
second fall now we tend to think that in
the bible there's one fall but really
the book of genesis especially up to the
up to the flood is just a series of
subsequent falls and it's important to
understand that of course once again in
order to understand the book of enoch
because the book of enoch describes one
aspect of these multiple falls an aspect
which is becoming more and more
cosmic which starts with adam falling
and that fall has repercussions and
starts to have waves and waves as the
garments of skin get bigger and thicker
and there needs more protection against
the world of death then that leads
ultimately to a breakdown
now of course as you know the story uh
cain and abel i won't go into the
details of why but cain
uh offers a sacrifice to god and is
rejected abel offers a sacrifice to god
and it's accepted and because of that
cain once again
lets go of his desires becomes obsessed
becomes uh
bitter becomes angry and
through that kills his brother abel now
the killing of of abel is now something
like a second fall and we need to
understand it that way because when we
look at what god says to cain we'll see
that there's a direct reflection with
what god says to adam so he says so now
you are cursed from the earth which has
opened its mouth to receive your
brother's blood from your hand when you
till the ground it shall no longer yield
its strength to you a fugitive and a
vagabond you shall be on the earth so
remember now when god told
adam he said you know by the toil of
your brow that you will be able to get
your bread from the earth and now he
says to cain
it's even worse it's like now it will no
longer yield its strength to you it's
becoming more and more impossible
to live in this world of death the world
where there's a break there's a breaking
apart between heaven and earth which is
manifesting itself in different ways and
this of course means that cain also
loses his home and adam moves away from
the garden down the the mountain you
could say and now kane is going even
further out from the the garden of eden
and will become a wanderer won't even
have a place that he can call his own
anymore and
now opposed to that so you can
understand that just like god gave adam
and eve garments of skin in order to
protect them in the world of death now
cain goes further out or further down
into the world of death and now he needs
a bigger protection which is why there
seems there seems to be an opposition
there seems to be an opposite
uh going on [ __ ] because cain is the
one that builds the first city so it
says and he built a city and he called
the name of the city after the name of
his son
so i've some people think that's a
strange contradiction but it's not a
contradiction no more than it is that
adam and eve fall move out of the garden
and now they don't have a place to
protect them or a balanced place and so
they have to add this layer of death to
protect them from death now in order for
at for cain to be protected from his
wandering he needs to increase the
garments of skin and now he makes them
something like social garments of skin
and so he creates a wall not around a
person but a wall around a whole
community of people so we can see the
fall becoming bigger and bigger it
starts with a person now it's becoming a
fall which which takes into account
entire groups of people this has to do
in itself with the fragmentation of the
human person the multiplication of the
human person into now families and
groups and different individual and
different clans which will clash and
which will
come to oppose each other ultimately as
they build
cities around them now
you can understand that the
let's say the relationship between
building a city and the fall and the
fall into opposites because as you
create walls around spaces you are
creating harder opposites you're
creating a sense of inside and outside
which is becoming more and more
prominent now
what happens let's say what what what if
you would put let's say you know
you have a you have a house and so you
put somewhere in your house a
a uh
you put a vault like a big vault
you know what's going to happen to
people what are you telling people when
you put
a vault somewhere what you're telling
them is that there's something precious
there there's something worthy of your
desire and so by hiding something you
also are enticing more desire and so in
order let's say you can see it you're
protecting
something and by protecting it then
you're also
making it more desirable and so there's
an increase you could say that something
can increase in the fall which happens
by the very process of creating these
opposites more and more now
down in the descendants of kane you will
have the different aspects of all
technology all civilization will be
created by his descendants and so kane
has several descendants we come to
lamech who has three sons sorry i wrote
two sons he has three sons he has jabal
jubal and tubal kane so jabal is the
father of those that dwell in tents so
even the nomadic people
the jubal is the father of those who
play the harp and flute so you have a
sense of even everything that's related
to the arts all of that is also related
to the descendants of kane and then
tubal kane who is an instructor of every
craftsman in bronze and in iron
and now we have the creation of weapons
of course and so the fall increases
as this is happening so here we have a
nice little image of tubal kane of jubal
and jabal together
it's hard to imagine them getting along
though but you know in this image
they're all together just because they
bring about all the war and all the
chaos
all right and so now in scripture
there's that weird little sentence
which comes after all of this
it says there were nephilim on the earth
in those days and also afterwards when
the sons of god came into the daughters
of men
and they bore children to them they were
mighty men who were of old men of renown
so this is a very mysterious verse
nephilim is something like the fallen
ones it's translated as giants in other
places it appears in scripture
of course when the israelites enter the
promised land and encounter these giants
and so there's a sense in which there's
a relationship between this fallenness
and the giants and the increase and so
a way to understand it is you can also
see that there's a relationship between
the increase of the fall itself as it
becomes more and more cosmic and the
description of these great and mighty
men
think about it it's very simple to think
about the creation of the city and the
increasing of the body that way what
does that create well it will ultimately
create mighty men because now if people
are able to ascend up these
these hierarchies in the world then they
have more power and so a king of a city
is of course more powerful than an
individual his body is bigger so there's
a sense in which this is of course what
the nephilim or the giants are related
to they are now whether or not they were
giants actually physical giants that's
also possible it doesn't bother me at
all whether that would be the case but
it's important to understand it more
than it is to think of whether you know
what it looked like let's say physically
or not it's mostly important to
understand that there's a relationship
between an increase of fall an increase
of animality an increase of body as the
garments of skin get added and get
bigger so you have something like giant
you have these gigantic creatures that
are very very powerful um
and so you see a few images of giants of
course the one is david and goliath who
is also
related to this because the different
tribes of giants which are encountered
in israel
you know as israel regains its territory
are related narratively and not just
narratively but even in terms of name
and in terms of the connection in the
text itself to the nephilim that are
there uh before the flood i talked about
this in other talks i won't go into it
too much but it's important to
understand that this type of story is
there everywhere so when scripture talks
about the idea of of men of renown we
can understand it as heroes in general
and the heroes of course that appear in
ancient mythologies any ancient
mythology has a sense in which the
origin of their civilization of their
great cities of their powerful things
were demigods that is they were half god
half man and that usually their father
was a god and their mother was a human
sometimes it's the opposite but most of
the time that's what it is and so this
appears in every culture here we have an
image of gilgamesh of course and
hercules that are these
these uh these
powerful men that were very terrifying
we all we always have to remember that
when the old world talks about these
demigods and these heroes they're not
talking about heroes the way we
understand heroes today but are really
talking about heroes in the sense of
these very powerful
tariff
terrible beings and i chose of course
gilgamesh because gilgamesh would
manifest this power over his
let's say
uh political body by wanting to sleep
with all the women in his
in his uh kingdom so he would go and you
know on the first night of someone's
wedding he would sleep with the man's
wife before his the man had access to
her it was a way to let's say embody the
entire body politic and kind of have his
strength and his power fill up the world
and so he can understand someone like
gilgamesh as a giant in many ways
because he was that
that being that had a very large and
powerful body and was very powerful in
the world and because of that was able
to to accomplish great deeds now you see
the same of course in the terms of
hercules was very strong he did all
these amazing feats but hercules was a
terrible man he
killed all his children and nonetheless
is still considered a hero so we have to
think differently about the heroes and
understand that when scripture talks
about these men of renown these men that
are related to you know the the sons of
god that came and
had encounters with with uh
with human women as this way of
understanding it and
one of the things that's important to
really get as we come into the book of
enoch is to understand that there are
true traditions in the christian world
one is that there were the sons of god
that came to the daughters of men refers
to angels and the daughters of man
referred to the daughters of cain and
there's another tradition which is that
it's the daughter the
the sons of seth the sethites those that
replaced abel as the chosen one you
could say as the the one who carries the
legacy of adam into the future that it's
them who now came and
came to the to the daughters of of of
cain of cain now
those two traditions of course they're
they're very different in their
narrative but they're not so different
in their implications they're they're
not so different in their implications
because they
they both imply a fall they both imply
something from above coming down and
joining with something from below
in in an act of desire and in that act
of desire
it ends up manifesting itself in bigger
bodies more powerful bodies patterns
from above which are brought down into
the world below or authority from above
which is brought down into the world
below in a way in which kind of fills up
the world with that authority and
creates these very powerful bodies so
although although those two traditions
some people might get annoyed that i'm
saying they mean the same for us for our
case it's more important to understand
their meaning and you can hold on to
whatever tradition you want that's fine
with me but i think it's important to
understand the meaning that we find in
the book of enoch because it is so
relevant to what what's going on today
now of course
all of this leads of course to the end
of a world and it says and god said to
noah the end of all flesh has come
before me for the earth is filled with
violence through them and behold i will
destroy them with the earth so all of
this this corruption this fall this this
focus on the body these bodies that
become bigger and heavier these
civilizations these cities that are also
related to desire remember that that's
why corruption fills the earth we're
going to see that more in the book of
noah how that all comes together is what
leads ultimately to the world now not
being sustainable anymore and falling
apart and so of course we get the flood
and noah's ark you know noah's ark is
often seen uh you know in the modern
world there's like a weird cute aspect
to noah's ark where you see toys and you
know puzzles and books for children but
noah's ark the story of noah is the most
terrifying story in scripture you know
it is so terrifying to imagine the
entire world collapsing under its own
chaos and violence uh and ultimately
only a few people uh the seed of the
righteous surviving
all right and so that's the basic uh
story in scripture to kind of talk about
how genesis the the creation narrative
leads all the way down into
the flood
and so what we see in the book of enoch
will be an expansion of this something
which will help us understand
what are the implications of this
narrative that's already there and even
as you notice i've teased out certain
elements from scripture which to some
people might not be obvious on the first
reading but uh you will understand that
the reason why i'm able to tease them
out is also because i've been formed by
other narratives like the book of enoch
which which were kind of this expansion
to help us see patterns in scripture
that are there but that are sometimes
hard to pick out for some people so the
the version of the book of enoch we're
going to look at is going to be the
first part of what often people call the
book of enoch or sometimes it's like
different enoch 1 2 3 or whatever
it's really the book of watchers which
is considered by
scholars to be the oldest part of the
book of enoch
composed in 300 to 200 bc
the complete text of the book of enoch
was found in ethiopia in i think in the
19th century if my memory serves me
correct
and the book of enoch is quoted in the
early church fathers but it's also
quoted in the bible it's quoted in the
epistle of jude
and it seems like there were parts of it
which were found in qumran and different
parts of the world
the book did come into let's say was
forgotten by some people or was kind of
set aside by some of the church fathers
because of the problem of the idea that
angels would have relationship with
women
and that would create children of course
that's very problematic for our
metaphysics but i think that especially
now and if if you're watching the or
listening to
the um lord of spirits podcast with
father stephen de young and father
andrew damick you will see that they
have been able to in my opinion they've
been able to really help us understand
what this means and how it's possible
and you know in a way that kind of heals
over the
the opposition or the
the problem that a lot of the later
ancients had with the book and the
answer is that these were rituals there
were rituals between that were set up
religiously between a priestly caste and
sometimes uh
temple prostitutes or sacred prostitutes
and that it was a ritualized way in
which to embody the god in the world
just like they had ritualized way of
embodying the gods and statues or you
know in the in temples and practices
then they had a way to sexually imbibe
the god into the world through ritual
sexual practice and that this really it
really kind of heals it together and it
also joins
it back to what i was talking about a
little bit before which is that this is
relation to related to civilizations
themselves it's related to
let's say religious practice
civilizations cultural dev developments
and that it's not just about you know
it's although narratively we can use the
image of the god coming down and having
an encounter with a woman we need to
kind of expand that and understand it
that it it has cultural and
civilizational implications all right
all right and so the book of enoch
starts with a kind of notion of the
coming revelation
it talks about how
you know enoch is the one who's speaking
and enoch knows that there's going to be
a flood so he kind of prepares the
reader to understand that and he says
he talks about how there will be a
manifestation of the holy one of god
himself who will therefore tread upon
mount sinai appear with his hosts and be
manifested in the strength
of his power of heaven as he talks about
how all shall be afraid and the watchers
will be terrified great fear and
trembling shall seize them even to the
ends of the earth the lofty mountain
shall be troubled and the exalted hill
depressed melting like a honeycomb in
the flame the earth shall be emerged and
all things which are in it will perish
while judgment shall come upon all even
upon all the righteous but to them he
shall give peace he shall preserve the
elect and towards them exercise clemency
so you get a sense in which he's telling
you now what i'm going to tell you is
what is going to bring about the end of
a world the world is going to end
but don't be worried because the just
will be preserved and
god will show clemency to the just and
then what will happen is that once all
of this happens
there's going to be a strange
transformation and then all will belong
to god
so then shall all belong to god be happy
and blessed and the splendor of the
godhead shall illuminate them and so
there's a sense in which this fall will
lead to a final you know apocalypse a
final revelation in which all things
will now become connected again you can
already see that there's a similar
version of this in the book of
revelation itself where the destruction
of the world leads to the new jerusalem
we'll talk about that a little later as
well and how it relates to the book of
enoch and to cain and the building of
the city i've talked about this in other
videos but we'll go over it nonetheless
so what's interesting is that the book
starts by describing natural patterns
and so we need to understand how the
ancients understood and how the notion
of the watchers were understood by these
people it was that god had appointed on
the world these angels that were
watchers that were those who were
principalities over different patterns
of the world they were the combination
of these patterns into intelligences and
these intelligences manifest themselves
in the world through these regular
natural patterns and so that's why
at first it really it describes just the
patterns of nature and it says
all who are in the heavens know what is
transacted there they know that the
heavenly luminaries change not their
path see
that each rise and set regularly
everyone at its proper period without
transgressing the commands which they
have received they behold the earth and
understand what is there transacted from
the beginnings to the end of it they see
that every work of god is invariable in
the period of its appearance they behold
summer and winter perceiving that the
whole earth is full of water and that
the cloud the dew and the rain refresh
it so they go on to describe different
different
natural patterns but what's important to
understand is that the way it's
described is that these watchers are set
over these regular patterns because
these patterns are intelligible and they
are intelligent they are causal in the
world
the patterns that we see in the heavens
they legislate
the different transformations that we
see that are stable that are balanced
the change of the seasons you know the
water which comes down from the
mountains down into the ground goes back
up and then comes down as rain these
types of natural patterns have a
regularity to them especially those in
the heavens the lights up in the heaven
have a regularity that regularity to
them so you need to understand that if
you don't understand that for the
ancients in the old in the bible that
the stars and the gods the stars and the
heavens the stars and these
principalities
are the same because they are a
manifestation of the regular patterns of
god's will
on the world and so god's will is
nothing but the regular procession of of
orderly patterns into
reality and so that is what these
principalities are uh above that's what
they
they are the watchers they watch over
these patterns
it's hard for us to think that way it's
it's easier for us to think that way
once we see them start to go off key and
when the patterns start to go off what
they're supposed to be then it's going
to become clear to kind of understand
them as these intelligences that are
acting in the world because you know
when they act outside of the script
let's say we can see the effects of them
because those other effects right the
effects of the natural patterns they
become like the they just become taken
for granted they're just the world we
live in they're not they they don't they
don't they tend to fall into the
background of our existence because they
just are let's say the the water in
which we live the natural patterns of
the world
so what happens is that of course you
have these intelligences that now fall
into the world
and they do that by desire they see what
that which is below and instead of just
being uh let's say a normal
let's say in the normal hierarchy of
things of overseeing the patterns of
being the combination of these patterns
they now through desire want to come
down and find
let's say bodies and we can understand
that this happens also from below so the
intelligences above you can describe it
as them desiring
the the
the feminine that is below the potential
is below and desires to
come into that through a desire to
modify and to transform the patterns to
their own
to their own power you could say
and another way to understand it is to
understand it from below as well to
understand that the that the men that
the descendants of cain in order to
protect themselves looked up and with
desire just like adam and eve reached up
in order to take the fruit of the
knowledge of good and evil reach up and
now take these patterns for themselves
not only to see them like was described
at the outset you know at the outset
these patterns are described as good as
beautiful as powerful these secret
patterns that are there in the world are
are are part of the way god lays out the
creation but now there's a sense in
which people reach up into those secrets
grab the secrets and use them to make
themselves more powerful
and that's very important that it's a
repetition of the fall but now it's
really at a cosmic scale and it's
related to desire which is why there's a
sexual aspect to it it's related to
multiplicity of beings and also to the
creation of giant bodies you know these
giant bodies represented by the
different levels of
civilization and everything all right so
so these fall intelligence they took
wives each choosing for themselves whom
they began to approach and with whom
they cohabited teaching them sorcery
incantations and the dividing of roots
and trees and the women conceiving
brought forth giants so there's a
relationship between
the the union of the
intelligences and the women
right and the bringing down of knowledge
those two things are the same
they really are the same they're
bringing down the knowledge into a world
that
grasps for them with desire and so it
says that the stature of these giants
was 300 cubits which is i think it's
like what is like a something like a
football field it's like 300 feet or
something like that i i think maybe even
more than that i don't know it's 300
yards or something it's huge it's it's
just it's just these huge huge
things by the way the the size of the
giants described in the book of enoch is
the same as the size of the ark
the ark of noah this helps you
understand even more what this is about
that it is about the technology itself
it is about the building of these giant
uh garments around us to protect us to
give us power to help us act in the
world of danger so we need to understand
by the way that noah's ark is a
continuation of this and the
transformation of this into
a good
but at this point
saying that that the giants had bodies
that were 300 cubits is to help us
understand that there's a relationship
between that and the ark itself
but what's important is that also
there's a sense in which now that these
giants have bodies now these giants
devour
they eat they're hungry they eat the
world they devour all which the labor of
men produced until it became impossible
to feed them and then they turned
against men and they started to devour
men now
understand that you can understand it in
a narrative way as these giants that
have giant bodies that just eat and eat
and eat but you can also of course
understand what it can also refer to in
terms of civilizational manner you can
imagine these cities that devour that
devour through the desire of its elites
that kind of gathers in gathers in and
it also devours men this is of course
what even you know the the prophet
samuel told the israelites that if they
have a king that the that king will
devour their children that king will
take their sons and their daughters to
fight in his war to his his daughters to
have children with to have this to sleep
with and and their their uh
their sons in order to fight in their
wars so there's there's a relationship
even there in terms of
narratively what it is that is being
referred to here um
and so they began to injure birds beasts
reptiles and fishes to eat their flesh
one after another and to drink their
blood and the earth reproved the
unrighteousness and so people notice
that these large huge gigantic bodies
are out of control and that they're
devouring the world and so think about
already think about in terms of the
ecological narrative the way in which we
describe the civilizational problem in
which we're in in terms of the way in
which we are devouring resources because
of our giant bodies we have these giant
bodies that are out of control that are
devouring resources and are also
devouring humans of course you know this
becomes clear and clear especially when
we look at um
when we look at google and we look at
social media and the internet and how it
devours us right it lives through our
attention our attention feeds it and
makes its body bigger and more powerful
um and fills makes it fill up the world
even more and so what's important also
to understand is the difference because
later in the in the other parts of the
book of enoch later enoch will ascend up
into heaven and as he ascends into
heaven he will himself discover all the
secrets of the way in which the world
lays itself out it's a it's a beautiful
narratively described
vision of the cosmos of these gates
these gates out of which the different
heavenly bodies come in and come out and
how they process regularly through the
sky at their allotted time and so
there's a sense in which
enoch will discover these secret
mysteries that are referring to but
there's a difference between that let's
say
um
enoch ascending up into the heavens and
discovering the secrets and now these
these intelligences coming down into the
world and modifying the world
that is what ultimately technology is
technology is a modification an adding
on of you know the earth onto things in
order to make them more powerful so it
is once again an acceleration of the
garments of skin themselves but now it
becomes more and more so it says talks
especially about azazel as a zell is
important in this
and
is important as well because azazel ends
up in the bible azazel is also in
scripture he's the demon of the
wilderness to which the israelites
sacrifice a goat
every year
and so moreover azazel taught men to
make swords knives shields breastplates
the fabrication of mirrors the
workmanship of bracelets and ornaments
the use of paint the beautifying of the
eyebrows the use of stones of every
valuable and select kind and all sorts
of dyes so that the world became altered
what's important is to understand the
world became altered and what's also
important to understand is what is the
strange relationship between all these
different aspects of reality
he makes swords and knives and shields
and breastflights but then also mirrors
and bracelets and ornaments and the use
of paint and beautifying the eyebrows
now of course all of this has to do with
metal making it has to do with taking
the minerals from the earth and
transforming them because of course
mirrors at that time would be made of
metal and also even the
the beautifying of the eyebrows uh was a
was a certain metal that was used to um
to paint the eyebrows of of women but it
also shows you the relationship between
power
and desire
the relationship between
you know getting swords and weapons and
making yourself more powerful
in order to
conquer others and protect yourself from
others and also the desire to make
yourself more attractive and more
beautiful
through
adding ornaments through adding this
layer on top of you of paint and of
beautifying your clothing of doing all
that in order to attract others so you
can see that this relationship between
desire and power is there by the way
right right in the beginning with adam
and eve in the garden with eve there at
the tree but it also now has you can see
its implications in terms of
civilization how there is a relationship
between all of these together so what
this does is of course impaiting
increases fornification fornication
multiplies and they transgress and
corrupt it all their ways
unless you understand that you won't
understand the relationship between
fornication and technology now it's a
lot easier to kind of understand for us
if you just take a second to see the
relationship between fornication and
technology if you think of course of uh
of contraceptives if you think of
pornography if you think of you know
this the the the internet and just how
elated it is with with eroticism
you can kind of see it but you can
sometimes it's hard to understand the
connection that it has to do with power
and desire that is the desire to
increase my
power in the world to to accumulate
these goods to accumulate these statuses
that i can get by a nice car or this or
that is related also to making myself
attractive and also you know say
joining with with sexually with things
and with people
there's this there's a relationship
between this desire and power which is
unavoidable and which is of course
represented very beautifully and
powerfully in the story of the book of
enoch
and this ultimately
although it was done in a way through
the pa through the desire of these
intelligences to be embodied but then
also the the desire of men the desire of
the descendants of cain to be more
powerful
what it ultimately does though is it
leads to the destruction
of men
and so you see all the different demons
that are teaching different things i
won't go through all of them you know
teaching sorcery the dividing of roots
observation of the stars signs astronomy
the motion of the moon and so like i
said all of these patterns they later
will be discovered by enoch himself in
scripture but these are all used to
control and to
modify reality rather than just a let's
say a spiritual contemplation and
participation in the way the world is
and then so that leads to men being
destroyed and it says and then men being
destroyed cried out and their voice
reached out to heaven
and the man in which the voice reached
out to heaven is that you have now these
intelligences that
became deviated that started to want to
find body for their own desires and now
you but you also have the intelligences
that remain stable that remain
uh
directed towards the infinite directed
towards god and so the way it works is
that the the
voice of those that are falling the
voice of those that are being destroyed
by this call up to heaven and then you
have the archangels my cable michael
gabriel kaphel suriel and uriel they
look down from heaven and see the
quantity of blood which was shed on the
earth and all the iniquity which was
done
upon it
and so they hear the voice of them and
then they turn up to god and they tell
they ask god to do this so the earth
deprived of their children has cried
even to the gate now it's the angels
saying the angels are telling god the
earth deprived of her children has cried
even to the gate of heaven and now to
you
and now to you you holy ones of heaven
sorry i'm still it's still now the
people that are that are complaining to
the angels says and now to you the holy
ones of heaven the souls of men complain
saying obtain justice for us with the
most high so they're telling now the
angels not to come down let's say and
and uh
and mingle with them but he's they're
looking up and they're asking the those
those principalities above to obtain
justice from that is what is above them
they're saying go up into into the
hierarchy and and
call upon god for us to now bring
justice down to us you can think of it
as the way in which for example in the
old testament the people would go to the
prophet and ask the prophet to pray for
them or go to the priests and ask the
priest to pray for them and now you can
see this at a higher level they're
asking up to say intercede for us to god
above intercede through us to to god and
that's what happens
and
finally what's interesting is that god
finally lays down his judgment and
there's an interesting little tidbit in
the way that god judges
that is very fascinating and can help us
understand what exactly the judgment of
god is
and we often think of the judgment of
god as this arbitrary thing that comes
down from heaven you know throwing
lightning bolts uh just god is angry so
he sends down his
his anger and there's a way in which we
need to understand that that's real that
the anger of god is a real thing that
that if the world goes against what it's
supposed to be if it starts to move in
directions that are counter its nature
then then the anger of god comes down
upon us but that anger of god is the
very result of us going away from
what god wants it's in the very pattern
of moving away so the distortion of
reality the modification of reality
towards our perversions and our desires
is what is going to destroy us itself
and so interestingly enough god turns to
gabriel and says
go to the biters the reprobates to the
children of fortification and destroy
the children of fortification
right the offspring of the watchers
these giants go destroy them from among
men bring them forth and do what and
excite them one against another let them
perish by mutual slaughter
for the length of days shall not be
theirs so you can understand that
the truth of these perverted patterns at
some point starts to
manifest itself and how does it start to
manifest itself it starts they start to
manifest themselves as their incapacity
to exist
so the truth of these patterns is that
people will fight amongst each other and
so god is saying gabriel excite in them
this
this capacity to fight against another
but that's in their very pattern of what
they're doing as well
in that pattern of desire in that
pattern of of trying to be more powerful
to be more vain to be more attractive to
attract more attention all of that will
lead us against each other and so that
is where the truth of those horrible
patterns start to manifest themselves
and it means that people start to fight
and they self-destroy ultimately and so
you could so you could think of it you
know
like you know you know someone someone
someone who starts to take uh heroin and
they take heroin and then at some point
you could say you know the judgment of
god is on that person but it's just it's
actually also just the consequences of
them taking heroin that is the truth of
that pattern of taking heroin is that
it's not sustainable if you do it
constantly then at some point it starts
to
starts to break apart and you know you
start to self-destroy and that appears
as the judgment of god all right
now
it's important to understand that this
story of these intelligences which come
down like i mentioned before the the
story that you find for example of the
the god the greek gods or the
mesopotamian gods that now encounter
humans and become the kings and the
leaders of these civilizations you can
also see versions that are related to
technology and
it's very interesting because you'll
notice that all the same patterns are
there
so for example
we have the story of course of the titan
and there's a weird relationship in
let's say uh
ancient imagination between the titans
and the giants although they're not
actually the same in hesiod for example
they end up kind of all becoming the
same these these these these fallen
these ancient gods and then also these
giants that are
the that are the side effect of uh of
kind of
of relationships that of uh heaven being
castrated and his semen kind of falling
on to the
chaotically onto the world you can
understand that these angels that come
down into the world and chaotically
manifest to bring about transformations
is not it's not exactly the same but you
can understand how it's related to let's
say heaven being castrated and his seeds
getting spread out chaotically and
bringing about these giants but you can
also understand that the titans of
course are the first rebels against the
god of heaven for the ones who rebel
against the god of heaven and prometheus
would have been in that clan of those
that rebelled against heaven and now
brought down
the patterns into the world and brings
fire to the world so what's interesting
is that in the greek myth most of the
time it's this is actually seen as
positive that this is a positive thing
right prometheus brought down
the the patterns of heaven into the
world to modify creation and this was
like you know an act of
a desire to liberate humans to liberate
them from the tyranny of heaven and if
you know people that are luciferian in
their thinking even if they don't know
that that's what they are some people
actually do they'll realize that that's
also how they see the fall in the garden
of eden they see it as something like
the promethean
relationship but what's interesting is
that the
punishment that is given upon prometheus
which is often seen as horrible and
unjust is that every day his liver uh
will will grow
and and then every day an eagle which is
the symbol of zeus will come down and
eat his liver every day uh what's
interesting is that the liver was for
the ancient greeks was seen as the house
of emotions and so the liver was the
place of emotions in the body so you can
understand that also as the passions if
you want is that the
prometheus's passions because he brought
down these patterns to heaven
through a rebellion against heaven
itself that his passions will cycle and
will constantly be brought back then
we'll be taken away then we'll be
brought back and will be taken away and
you can understand it as the cycle of
any passion of any desires of any time
that you you act in desire and you end
up in this cycle where you're never
really satisfied and you keep you keep
turning in a circle in a circle so you
can see it of course in the story
prometheus but you can see it a lot even
more clearly in the story of the
minotaur now
in the story of the minotaur
there is the story of
pacifi
who is the king of the the the wife of
the king of minos
and the the gods they make this beaut
they give this beautiful bull to the
king aminos i forget who gave it to him
it gets complicated i i forget these the
the details but the they have this
beautiful white bull and they entice
pacifier to fall in love with the bowl
and to want to have a relationship with
the bull now you can see interestingly
enough how
it's it's
it's inverted right it's it's a it's a
weird inverted relationship
but it's still very similar it's like
this crossing of levels of ontological
reality of different levels of
principality which are crossed through
irregular desires and this irregular
desire causes monsters and causes chaos
and causes violence and and breakdown so
pacifie falls in love with the bull
wants to engage with it obviously cannot
so what did she ask she asked daedalus
who is the great technician he's the
great artificer to create a
animal shell for her so he creates this
animal shell around her and a fake bowl
in which she goes into and by hiding
herself in this animal shell then she
can enter into relationship with the
white bull and that's how she gives
birth to the minotaur and of course the
minotaur is a cannibal he goes around
and eats people and he has to be hidden
in the labyrinth in order to prevent his
he the chaos that that has been
unleashed in the world of hybrids and
mixtures it's important to understand
that um in some traditions
the nephilim of course also created
hybrids it was part of their it's part
of what they were doing so you can see
of course
the notion of hybridity is related to
all of this that is you can understand
the angels the ids high identities or
these high intelligences that cast
themselves down into these lower
causalities through desire and so mingle
and create
um
create more and more mixture in terms of
confusing of identities it's already a
confusing of identity for of course you
know pacifier to have a relationship
with the bull it's a confusion of
identity for these higher beings to
mingle with these lower beings but then
that also creates these these different
uh
this different mixture which is at the
bottom of the world the place where
identity breaks down right the dust of
the earth where things start to fall
apart and not hold together there's of
course an image of that in the in the
vision of daniel where you see you know
the
head of gold you know the different
metals of the different section of the
statue ending with the mixture of clay
and iron at the bottom so you can
understand that the hybrids that these
giants create and the hybrids that were
created by the relationship between
pacifier and the bull is something like
these hybrids and this confusion of
identity which brings about chaos and
death at the edge of the world it's of
course related once again that i
mentioned the fact that in manuscripts
you have all these hybrids on the board
of manuscripts but it's also related
let's go back to the very top of this
it's also related to the way in which
demons themselves
are represented in western iconology
these demons themselves are represented
already
as this mixture and this chaos and these
and these animals that are you know
birds and mammals and lizards that have
faces you know faces on their crotches
that are you know they're that are
falling upside down
all of this is a representation
of already this problem of what happens
when these identities fall and how they
start to break down and to fragment into
hybrids now of course all of this leads
to the flood which is the breakdown of
everything
and you know the place in which all of
this falls apart identities collapse
violence is too much there's too much
opposition there's too much chaos
there's too much breakdown
um and it all falls apart into the flood
and the flood is caused by all of these
different factors at the same time this
can really help us understand the modern
world and can help us understand the
modern crisis and i think that
in order to kind of understand the
modern crisis the first thing we have to
understand
is that the modern world is not only
born out of technical knowledge that is
there's a direct relationship between
technical knowledge and the relationship
with angels there's a direct
relationship between
in the west between this technical
rationalistic point of view and this
weird esoteric
uh angiology and demonology which
occurred at the end of the middle ages
and start to started to
become more and more prominent now you
can look into these figures yourself i'm
not going to to go into detail but just
to help you understand that at the very
outside of modernity during the during
the enlightenment period you have
figures like john d
who was the main counselor of the of
queen elizabeth who was a
who was a magician who was a you know a
hermeticist who was all these things now
what's most important to understand here
that one of the things that he tried to
do was to contact angels he tried to
have he tried to
receive messages from these beings that
were above and these beings ultimately
led him himself into
a lot of confusion and led him to
practice white swapping and things with
his partner and it just became very
weird and disturbing but there are many
examples of that you can look these up
joseph
who was a french
kind of decadent
uh religious figure in the uh the 19th
century
who led to what's known as the symbolist
the symbolists were a uh it's funny
because i'm a symbol it's not the same
kind of symbolism but these symbolists
were these artists at the end of the of
the 19th century that explored the
spiritual but in very kind of dark terms
you see it in uh painting you see it
also in uh in
in the music
a lot of the music uh a lot of these
kind of dark you know the the sabbath of
witches and all of these types of
imagery were explored by these people of
course you have blavatsky and you have
crowley who practice sex magic and
demonology
and of course i've mentioned this before
and i mentioned this in another podcast
and i mistook the name of of crowley's
uh
one of crowley's beans which was lamb
who he was having encounters with and
which and who was dictating uh you know
knowledge to him and it's just
interesting because lamb looks like a
gray and there's a relationship direct
relationship between
you can understand that in the in the
enlightenment period there are some
people trying to break through
and to kind of recontact these
intermediary beings you could say and
this was directly related to uh the
development of technology these same
people were also
um
they were directly related you can't
it's hard to to to get a get away from
that but now we can understand the
giants we can understand that
giants have been unleashed on our world
and
we see it of course in terms of this
armament we see it in terms of the
physical corruption you know in the
ecological crisis pollution we see it of
course with the obsession with hybrids
and that this is related
and is inextricable from moral
corruption now people tend to not want
to see those related together but they
because of course a lot of people that
are involved in the moral corruption are
decrying the physical corruption but
they don't realize that the desire that
is bringing about the moral corruption
the confusion of sexual identities and
the desire to live
out your sexuality in the completely
disincarnated disembodied uh you know uh
way
is related to the desire to increase
your power in terms of technology so
that you don't have to submit yourself
to the natural patterns of the world
right we have the electricity which
means we don't have to follow the
patterns of the lights in the sky we
have cars which means that we can spread
ourselves out we can move faster we can
do all these things which are
modifications of nature um and that the
desire we have that the desire that we
have to kind of
engage with that in an obsessive way is
the same desire which leads to the moral
and the sexual corruption let's say and
this of course leads to a destruction of
humanity whether it is a destruction
through you know people getting sick
because of because of pollution because
our food is technological and our food
is degrading the quality of our food is
degrading people become uh
you know people use contraceptives
pornography all of this technically
brought about this relationship between
technique and desire brings about a
fallen birth rate and ultimately
of the vision of a collapse and i think
that it's interesting because although i
do believe that the environmental
narrative is often weaponized by people
who want to control it and people who
want to bring about their own very
disturbing uh luciferian utopia
there is nonetheless a reality which is
that some of these machines that we've
unleashed on the world
they are very dangerous to us you know
the just the idea of nuclear war is not
a joke that exists it's possible that
nuclear destruction will visit upon us
you know i was talking to brett
weinstein
uh i think the podcast should be coming
already come out by the time you see
this but he mentioned you know that
there are hundreds of nuclear
reactors in the united states that
require 24-hour uh electrification
and so it's like
if the electricity stops they will
melt down
and there are hundreds of these so it
means that
there's a man in which we're acting as
if
we want power and power and power and we
have no sense of calculating
what this means in terms of the
modification of the world in which we
live and this is important to understand
that
now
the question to understand now
ultimately the key to how this is
related to
fallen angels and to you know these
falling watchers is
these patterns they are active
intelligences
and nobody controls them
because we often think that these things
just exist in the world and that they
don't act upon the world but
the man in which we can kind of see that
they don't that they act
upon the world is that we don't control
them
a good example is of course the
environmental crisis itself which is
that although our politicians use
environmental environmental crisis
politically to spot to do whatever it is
that they want to do
everybody kind of understands that
whoever backs away from
this increasing of power is going to
lose politically
and that if we if we now back down then
china will win
and so the mechanism of its of its
implications in the world are playing
themselves out in a way that nobody
can stop anymore
because they have they have their boots
in the reality and are making reality
move
in a certain direction
and a good example of a good example
that we see in uh stories is this idea
of course of the genie in the bottle
that is you know you you ask a genie for
something your desire what's your desire
and you understand that the genie is the
pattern that has all the power to
implement it in the world so you connect
those two together this intermediary
kind of
angelic or patterned figure that is
fallen that's why he's trapped in this
lamp he's trapped in the world and now
he says what is your desire so you tell
him your desire and then what happens
you get your desire but then because you
engage with that pattern not through
true knowledge not through true kind of
ascending knowledge where you you
encounter and embody and understand the
pattern but because you do it with
desire you don't understand the pattern
you're invoking
and therefore all the ramifications that
you hadn't planned on start to play
themselves out and now you have there's
no you have no control over it so you
you ask for something and then all the
side effects of what you asked for start
to appear that's of course the classic
story of the genie and a good example of
that is of course the automobile
we
we wanted the automobile people wanted
the automobile because they could see
that it would make them more powerful it
would increase their speed would
increase their capacity to travel long
distances um but what that led to
people didn't realize at the outset that
it would lead to the reorganizing of our
entire society to the reorganizing of
the way that cities are planned the way
that all communities function that we
would create these these suburbs with
just houses and when we create these
shopping centers with just stores and
then we would create these cultural
centers where you go to see movies and
you go to the theater and that these
would all be disconnected and so be and
because of the car you could not you
could live in a world where you don't
interact with your neighbors because
you're constantly going to work 30
minutes there going to the store 30
minutes there visiting your family and
your friends that live an hour away and
it it it actually restructured
all of our society and it restructured
the very way in which our communities
existed and actually led to the fact
that communities ceased to exist it's
not the only factor but it definitely
led to the to the capacity for us to
exist without
without embodied community and that was
not of course i mean i'm sure that ford
that's not what he wanted that's that
wasn't in the plans but these patterns
they're intelligent they act upon the
world and they have their own will you
could say and once they're unleashed
then you cannot stop them
and some of these giants that you see
in
in scripture and that i've been telling
you about civilizations and armies or
bodies and these kind of big bodies that
exist in the world
that you know we've got one coming very
quick quick on us and it is of course
artificial intelligence we realize that
artificial intelligence nobody controls
it
nobody totally can see inside that black
box and it's so powerful and its
ramifications are impossible to fully
account for but everybody understands
that if you don't if you don't run that
race then you'll lose and so even though
someone like elon musk was saying
was warning everybody about artificial
intelligence just a few years ago he
realized that whoever doesn't
participate in the body of this
of this
emerging god
is going to lose and so nobody can stop
it even if you try
uh it's just going to happen and of
course uh nuclear weapons which sorry i
forgot to translate that one sentence
from my uh my presentation nuclear
weapons are of course the same because
it's the same you create nuclear weapons
the other person creates nuclear weapons
and then you create more and more and
it's very hard to come to a point where
you totally de-escalate because whoever
de-escalates
and whoever doesn't de-escalate even if
it's in secret is going to win
and so it has a it has a will of its own
that's kind of manifesting itself
through an intelligent pattern um so
that can also help you understand how
the deals we make with these
intelligences if we do it through desire
for power then they will lead to
destruction and that for itself is
the position in which we're in right now
for those that still hold on to a kind
of luciferian
vision of the world i think they should
be able to see that
to think that one more technical
one more technical move let's say is
going to
bring about the solution is to
misunderstand the very
way in which this is happening
and so
there is of course in our in our stories
in our narrative there is of course all
of these things come together and so the
relationship between aliens technology
the obsession with the imaginary fantasy
the the idea of fiction and fantasy all
of that how it comes together violence
sexuality hybrids cyborgs robots
psychedelics
this anti-human spell that we see this
idea that humans need to be transcended
and of course this weird opposition
between chaos and domination that fills
up all our fictional stories as well
it's just one more representation of
what it is that's kind of going on and
uh there it's not surprising that you
know some of the prominent orthodox
thinkers in the 20th century have
connected and other christian thinkers
have connected the relationship between
these fallen angels and this image that
we have of the graves and of these
aliens encounters how this related to
to uh technology how it's related also
to psychedelics if you look into the
relationship between the development of
apple computers and psychedelics you'll
see that all of this is kind of uh
coming together remember that the fallen
angels also taught people how to make
these drugs and to make these
concoctions you could say and that
there's a relationship between using
these concoctions to
go into the spiritual world without
truly ascending in moral virtue and in
transformation but it's like a shortcut
right to increase your power is also all
related to this as well
and
of course
this leads to the end of a world now
there's a when it talks about the end of
the world in the book of enoch it's an
interesting image and so of course it
talks about
you know the end of a world it talks
about the earth being emerged all things
are going to perish that the judgment
will come upon us all but it will come
upon even the righteous but to them he
shall give peace shall preserve the
elect
and towards them exercise clemency then
shall all belong to god be happy and
blessed and the splendor of the godhead
shall illuminate them so this sense in
which although this is all happening
this world is is collapsing and falling
apart that through this there's a
mysterious transformation operating
itself and that it is ultimately leading
to god filling all in all and that this
knowledge even though it was taken let's
say in ill will in passion and it leads
to destruction god can ultimately
transform that in true illumination and
true filling up uh of his presence in
reality i don't know how that works i
don't know how it happens but it's
definitely described in the book of
revelation as the heavenly jerusalem
which descends onto heaven and becomes a
perfect balance between the guardian and
the city between that moment of
innocence in the garden and now this
falling into knowledge to passion into
ultimately a true knowledge in the end
where things are integrated together so
the story does have a happy ending but
in the meantime
understanding the book of enoch can help
us on can help us see how
the patterns that are described in
genesis are one of the ways and one of
the keys to helping us understand how
the different manifestations of our
world are connected together how the
different ways things are breaking down
are not separate from each other but the
relationship between desire and power
and the breakdown the fragmentation the
the relationship between hybrids and
technology all of this is directly
described in is described in genesis and
then
let's say uh built upon in the book of
enoch and it help us it can help us
understand our situation now
and it can also help us understand
let's say the the way out which is to
move it's not it's important to
understand once again that it's not that
these technologies
are necessarily bad in themselves but
because they come about through desire
that's what leads to the destruction so
it all it but it does lead to the
possibility this whole imagery and the
imagery in the book of revelation to
understanding how
if things are in their proper place if
things are in their proper
function that they can lead to something
better and so hopefully
we can be a part of that at least on a
small scale at least around us to the
people that surround us so i hope this
has been helpful
it was a long kind of trek through the
book of enoch and uh how it's related to
to us today i hope it was helpful to
help you
understand what's going on and why this
book is important to understand again
today so thanks for your attention
everybody and uh we'll talk to you soon
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and uh thank
you for your support